what about genius
you know that sort of uh cliche saying
like the
madness and genius that they kind of
danced together uh
what about if the thing we see is this
order is actually genius unheard or
misunderstood
well here again the numbers help us and
here's where being rigorous and
quantitative actually really helps if
you look at disorders like autism
and bipolar disorder
and eating disorders anorexia nervosa
for example
these uh
you know particularly bipolar and
anorexia these can be fatal
they can cause immense suffering
but they are heavily genetic all three
of these
and
what's very interesting is each one of
these three is actually correlated
positively
positively with measures of intelligence
of educational
attainment and even of income
and so you look at this severe disorders
in many cases
causing
quite immense morbidity and mortality
and yet
they are positively correlated at the
population level with positive things
can you say the the three again autism
autism
anorexia and bipolar disorder bipolar
right what's that book forgot the book
name but uh is intelligence a burden
well you know people can get into
trouble when they think they're smarter
than they are i will say that
i don't know
sometimes like
in the deepest
meaning of that statement i think
ignorance is bliss i'm a big fan of
prince michigan from the idiot and um
i lost her from brother karmazov
optimism can be seen as naivete and
dumbness but i think it's a
it's a kind of deep intelligence
maybe inability to reason
uh sort of about the mechanics of the
world but instead kind of feel the world
and it seems like that's a one of the
paths to happiness
there is how much you think versus how
much you feel this comes up all the time
in medicine
we encounter this all the time when you
day after day you encounter this you
know the the abyss of suffering from
patients how much do you let yourself
feel
or how much do you
make it abstract and
and objective and try to make it
clinical
and that range how you're able to move
yourself on that on that spectrum
is very important for survival as a
physician
and the way you
you protect yourself and your feelings
turns out to be very important
you